[Musica]
[Applauso]
me lo sono chiesta un'infinità di volte
quale sia il segreto per scrivere una
bella canzone e cercherò anche stasera
di rispondere trovando la risposta più
opportuna con il vostro aiuto ma prima
vorrei partire dalla cosa che reputo più
importante è che riguarda tutti riguarda
me riguarda voi sì volevo parlare di
quella cosa lì che è un misto di scienza
poesia algebra mistero quella che
definisco una carezza ancestrale con cui
siamo stati pensati siamo stati generati
e ha fatto sì che poi crescessimo
avvolti da quella che un immensa e multi
sfaccettata armonia e lì tra un battito
un respiro lo stomaco che parla ci sono
delle note musicali che galleggiano
stanno lì vi aspettano di essere
catturate di essere captate ma allora
qual è questa tendenza che rende l'uomo
così vulnerabile al punto di di
fargliele cercare di fargliele inseguire
la musicofilia
questa parola che è stata così
sapientemente descritta dal
neuroscienziato e scrittore oliver sacks
quello che ha scritto risvegli per
intenderci che parla di questa tendenza
amorosa che all'uomo nei confronti della
musica anche quando non lo vuole e
questo riconoscere lei la meta di tanti
sentimenti la gioia il dolore
l'abbandono la frustrazione la nostalgia
bene ci rendiamo conto che la musica
esercita su di noi è un enorme potere
anche quando non la cerchiamo e
soprattutto anche quando non ci
riteniamo degli esseri particolarmente
musicali ed è proprio su queste parole
essere musicali che io vorrei riflettere
ma che differenza c'è tra essere
musicali ed essere un musicista e
soprattutto se poi rapportiamo queste
due parole all all'atto pratico di
creare una canzone
ma tutti quelli che sono musicali poi
diventano musicisti e soprattutto le
canzoni sono scritte soltanto da chi fa
musica da chi e musicale
beh in effetti siamo tutti i possessori
sani di musicofilia ma da solo non basta
ci sono molte persone musicali che non
diventeranno musicisti così come ci sono
molti musicisti che poi non scriveranno
nulla e poi ci sono un sacco di canzoni
che sono state scritte da persone che
non conoscevano per niente la musica ad
alcuni registratori portatili degli anni
settanta sono state affidate le bozze di
alcune tra le più belle canzoni di eric
clapton e dei beatles e perché loro non
la vigevano la musica e allora qual è
questa capacità che una persona deve
avere per scrivere una canzone
la capacità che una persona deve avere
prescrivere una canzone
e l'immaginazione
la capacità di immaginare la musica di
vederla dentro la testa anche quando non
c'è e per immaginare per immaginare la
musica come si impara dove si impara
per immaginare la musica serve
immaginare la musica così come ad un
bambino per camminare serve camminare
non ho mai visto un bambino di 10 mesi
con un compendio di anatomia di
fisiologia umana sulle spalle sulle
gambe aperto che legge per imparare a
camminare perché una capacità che
abbiamo tutti ce l'ho io e ce l'avete
anche voi sicuramente dobbiamo
riconoscerla è possibile anche ampliarla
è possibile acquisire altre competenze
ma siamo tutti siamo tutti i possessori
di questa capacità ora questa capacità
può essere di immaginazione involontaria
ti ritrovi in questo caso a pensare
delle note ad avere un motivetto in
testa ti fermi la mattina non ti ricordi
se la sognata ce l'hai lì che ti ronza
per la testa ci sono note note che
inseguiti galoppano e non siete dove
vengono perché sono estremamente nuove
ma sono anche estremamente familiari ed
entri in crisi ma c'è qualcuno che te la
suggerite no
ed è la stessa sensazione che ebbe poi
nei quando scrisse yesterday continuava
a chiedere ma siete sicuri che questa
canzone non sia stata già scritta perché
così perfetta così compiuta bene
dall'altra parte poi c'è l'immaginazione
musicale volontaria che quella dove
l'anticipazione e la suggestione hanno
un ruolo fondamentale
talmente forte da rendere
l'immaginazione stessa un esperienza
sensoriale quasi percettiva e a tal
proposito è stato fatto uno studio
bellissimo indoor mount dal dottor kelly
che ha scansionato la corteccia di tanti
pazienti con la risonanza magnetica
funzionale ed è stato visto che questi
pazienti esposti
all'atto di immaginare la musica
attivavano le aree uditive e le aree
frontali quelle che sono deputate
insomma all'intenzione alla
programmazione delle idee ma che fatto
straordinario e cioè se immaginiamo la
musica la sentiamo si è possibile ed è
una cosa che ci riguarda e che rende
l'esperienza della musica fili a
un'esperienza sensoriale collettiva a
portata di tutti bene io stasera
vorrei attivare la vostra immaginazione
musicale
vorrei scrivere con voi e immaginare una
canzone e per questo dovete avere già
attivato sicuramente il codice
siete pronti
perché vi chiederò di fare delle cose
anzitutto
sicuramente ormai è noto soprattutto a
questa categoria ha così
particolare che la categoria del
contenitore che sta a licola con il
pianoforte sulle spalle che riceve tutti
i giorni gli input da questi neuroni che
gridano a gran voce scegli me prendi me
ecco
sicuramente è tipico del cantautore
immaginare la musica ma potete farlo
anche voi benissimo possiamo partire dal
testo possiamo partire dalla musica
oppure testa in musica insieme stasera
ho scelto di partire dal testo voi avete
un ruolo importante perché sceglierete
anche l'ambiente musicale sceglierete il
testo e poi scriveremo il testo insieme
ok per facilità
ho chiamato i tre motivi che adesso
ascolterete motivo blu motivo arancione
motivo verde voi ascolterete e con il
vostro cellulare voterete il motivo che
sentite di più che vi piace di più
cominciamo con il primo motivo il motivo
blu
[Musica]
questo è il motivo blu adesso partiamo
con il secondo
quello arancione
[Musica]
e per finire il motivo verde
ok votate motivo verde motivo blu un
motivo arancio
[Musica]
lo ricordo
motivo arancione
[Musica]
quello verde
ok sembra di capire che c'è una
preferenza
del motivo verde ma io direi che ce lo
prendiamo per buono vince il motivo
verde e quindi questo paolo può più
bene a questo punto è arrivato il
momento di dargli un nome a questo
motivo verde e quale sarà il titolo
potete scegliere tra sopra le nuvole
ti penso ad agosto o la fine dell'estate
votate pure
[Musica]
intanto si compone
anche qui
[Musica]
vincerà la fine dell'estate o sopra le
nuvole
[Musica]
sa che sopra le nuvole sarà il titolo
della nostra canzone per voi va bene
ok sopra le nuvole a questo punto ora ci
divertiamo
pensate il 6 radi tipo di macchina avete
la radio accesa e sta arrivando questa
canzone che ha per titolo sopra le
nuvole
immaginiamo un testo il vostro testo
scrivete pure la prima cosa il primo
verso la prima fase che vi suggerisce
questa musica e soprattutto questo
titolo sopra le nuvole
scrivendo
vuole cosa fare
cosa incontrato
bene
vai
[Musica]
salento
sembravi
tutte
tufino
felice
macché
[Musica]
sentono
c'è
[Musica]
sopra lento
sopra le
cadendo
[Musica]
bono dice
sta assegnando
beh forse un giorno
[Musica]
libero
male
[Musica]
senza paura
bene
che dire
questo è il nostro esperimento e la
nostra canzone ma allora qual è il
segreto per scrivere una bella canzone
abbiamo visto che insomma c'è tanta
tecnica anche ma c'è tanto trasporto c'è
tanta tanto flusso di di melodie di
parole però se dovessi dirvi qual è
quella cosa che rende le vostre canzoni
speciali quelli che scriverete perché
adesso dovete andare a casa e dovete
scriverla scrivete il testo adesso
magari il titolo prendete un appunto e
continuate a casa
la canzone è bella sarà quella che avrà
la verità dentro perché la verità che
rende le vostre canzoni belle
perché noi abbiamo bisogno ad
immedesimarci in storie vere in
sentimenti veri
e se voi andando a casa avrete scritto
con sincerità la vostra verità credetemi
aver descritto sicuramente la canzone
più bella della vostra vita
grazie
[Applauso]